[JINGLE PLAYS]
SPEAKER: Please welcome,
from "Welcome to Night Vale,"
Cecil Baldwin.
[APPLAUSE]
CECIL BALDWIN: Hi everybody.
Welcome back from the weekend.
I want to say thank you so
much for the opportunity
to get to come and speak to you.
This is such a cool thing.
You all have a cool job.
And I have a cool job.
And I'm glad we get to
do that together today.
I just want to give you like
a little bit of background
about who I am, and what I
do, and this crazy, crazy job
that I have somehow
found myself in.
My name is Cecil Baldwin,
and I am an actor.
I did mostly theater,
classical theater,
a little bit of voiceover
stuff here and there.
And then, in my late 20s, I got
in with this theater company
called the New
York Neo-Futurists.
The New York Neo-Futurists--
I went to school
out in the Midwest.
Their flagship show, "Too Much
Light Makes the Baby Go Blind"
had run for like 25
years in Chicago.
It was like the hallmark
of late night theater.
Like, the more you drink, the
better we are kind of theater.
But it became this cult
phenomenon out in Chicago.
And then eventually some
people came to New York,
and they started the
New York company.
I went to school
out in the Midwest.
And so my college years
were filled with road
tripping up to Chicago and
seeing a normal play at eight,
and then go see "Too Much Light"
at 11:30, or whatever it is.
Then eventually, when I
made my way to New York,
I found out oh, there's
a New York company.
And I auditioned
and didn't get cast.
And then I auditioned
again and got cast.
But what's so funny
is that this theater
company the Neo-Futurists is
integral to the story of Night
Vale.
Because one of the writers
is a company member.
Joseph Fink, the guy whose
brainchild Night Vale is,
is a huge fan of the show,
and saw "Too Much Light"
over and over and over again.
Then I got involved directly
because of "Too Much Light."
So the whole hallmark
of the Neo-Futurists
is you are who you are,
you are where you are,
and you are doing
what you're doing.
It was in reaction
to the improv comedy
scene of the '80s in Chicago.
It's like, OK, we'll
just improv a scene
where I'm the Queen of England
and you're William Shakespeare,
and we'll just see
where the funny is.
And the Neos wanted
to get rid of all that
and just be like, no I'm Cecil.
I'm always me.
I'm standing in this room.
We're in New York City.
I'm at the Google building.
Like these are the
given of the situation.
And let's start from there
and see what we can get into.
So how does all this
apply to "Night Vale?"
If you've ever listened
to "Night Vale,"
you'll notice that
my character's name,
coincidentally enough, is Cecil.
And it was one of those things
where, when we first started,
we're like, well, the
character needs a name.
I guess we'll just
call it Cecil.
It's your name.
It's easy to remember, right?
Little did we know that would
later cause some consternation
down the line.
Me, Joseph, Jeffery,
the two writers, myself.
We had this idea to--
Joseph loves podcasts.
And he was this
frustrated writer
trying to make it in the
writing, publishing world,
and was frustrated with the
amount of gatekeepers that
are necessary to get published.
He published his own book.
I think he used
software designed
for creating greeting
cards in order to do that,
but it's was just
what he had available.
And he was working selling
green energy on the street
and putting together his books.
But he loved podcasts.
And he thought, well
this is literally
the lowest gate-keeper to
get your stuff out there.
So he had this idea
of a small desert
town where every conspiracy
theory you've ever heard
is not only true, but it's
just a part of everyday life.
He got Jeffrey Cranor on board,
who is a Neo-Futurist as well.
And then, I was currently
doing a little short play
with the Neos about how,
ever since I was a kid,
I had this sort of
radio announcer voice.
And somehow, I had yet
to be on the radio.
So Joseph heard this,
and was like, well, I'm
making this project
that needs this guy who
is like a NPR, public
radio character.
And you'd be perfect for that.
But in the creepiest,
weirdest possible way.
I read the script.
I read the pilot script.
And I absolutely loved it.
I'm a huge fan of David Lynch,
and David Cronenberg, and HP
Lovecraft, and all
these horror tropes
that were built into the
world of "Night Vale,"
but then takes them and
turns them on their head,
and then makes them interesting,
or abstract, or funny.
I immediately got
the tone right away.
We just started
making this thing.
I literally recorded it
in my apartment in Harlem.
Would have to turn off
all the air conditioners
and shut everything down
and unplug the fridge so it
didn't make any noise.
I have to do take
after take after take,
because I'd be in the middle
of a dramatic monologue,
and then all of a sudden the
ice cream truck would roll by.
There was an episode called
"Yellow Helicopters,"
and there were literally
helicopters circling
my apartment while I was
recording, which sounds cute,
until it's like hour
three, and you're like OK,
I just need to finish this.
I just need to finish
this one episode.
We just started
making this thing.
We had no idea
where it would go.
Then what was interesting
about this idea of going back
to these ideas of you are who
you are, you are where you are,
you're doing what you're doing--
I started incorporating
my own personality
into the performance.
I record by myself.
I'm kind of my own director.
So I do a take, and then
I go back and listen.
So I can use my actor brain,
finish that, and then go back
and use my director brain.
Because you can't do
both at the same time.
You can't do the thing and
also comment on the thing
while you're doing it.
You really have to
separate those out.
But as "Night Vale"
started to grow,
and as the plot
got more developed,
and as the world got more
developed, all of a sudden,
aspects of my own
personality started
to bleed into the
world of "Night Vale."
Early on, this character, Carlos
the scientist, was introduced.
And this character
was really just a foil
for the town of Night Vale.
Night Vale's this crazy
place where pterodactyls
appear suddenly
in a PTA meeting,
and then disappear
just as suddenly.
But from my point
of view as an actor,
trying to ground that in
a realistic, human place
was the most important thing.
So this character,
Carlos the scientist,
shows up, who's very normal.
And he's like, you know, your
town is really messed up,
right?
Let me explain to you all the
ways your town is messed up.
But he was described
as being this--
gorgeous hair, and gorgeous
teeth, and really just
shockingly beautiful.
And so, the first time I read
that, my initial reaction is,
OK, let's just say I live
in a town with 300 people,
and this beautiful
male model shows up.
I'd at least be intrigued,
and at the very most,
I'd be like, OK, this
guy's really cute.
So I started putting
more of that energy
into my performance, in making
this relationship develop.
Eventually, the writers
picked up on that.
And all of a sudden, we had
this canon gay relationship
at the heart of the show
that doesn't drive the show,
but he is nevertheless
an important part
of my character, the voice
that talks to you all.
Then over the
course of the show,
this Cecil and
Carlos relationship
actually became one of the lynch
pins that led to our success.
One of my favorite
things about the show,
is that there are very
few physical character
descriptions.
And this is really interesting
and very unusual these days.
There's so many popular
novels and stories and things
like that.
And it's all about what
the characters are wearing
and how they present themselves
to the outside world.
But in Night Vale, you have
a lot of people's actions
define who they are.
This character is Tamika Flynn.
She is a young teenager who is
a militia leader, of course,
and really, really loves
books and hates librarians.
Now, this is classic
"Night Vale,"
in that the mundane
becomes absurd,
and the absurd becomes mundane.
So something as usual
as a librarian--
all of a sudden in the
world of "Night Vale,"
librarians are these
mythical beasts
that want nothing more than
to eat people that love books.
This character,
Tamika Flynn, she's
made it her job to protect
Night Vale from the librarians.
But this incorporation
of people who
are outside of the
normal of what you
might see in everyday media--
actually I was just
listening to the Google Talk
with Aisha Tyler.
What's so interesting is that,
this is 10 years ago or so,
and here's this woman,
this black woman,
who was literally the first
black person on "Friends."
I think that set the tone for,
what is mainstream media doing,
and how are they reflecting
the world that we live in?
Being on the cult
end of things, where
we don't have
corporate sponsors,
we don't have a team of people
looking over our demographics
and going, oh, well you know
if you write this person on--
if you write a gay
character into the show,
you'll get this demographic,
that demographic.
What's great is
that we just do it.
We just put it out
there and let it roll.
Tamika is this strong,
feminist character,
person of color who is
kicking ass and taking names.
And that is-- the
color of her skin,
her sexuality, things like that,
are the least important thing
about her, and yet,
they're still present.
And "Night Vale"
is rife with these.
They're all over the place.
Of course, in "Night
Vale," angels exist.
This is another representation
of my character, Cecil.
As you can tell,
looks nothing like me.
But, you know what?
That's the joy of
doing a radio show,
is that these characters really
exist in the listener's mind.
When "Night Vale" first started
to become popular, there
was a huge debate over,
what does Cecil look like?
And I find this
really interesting,
because people want to
be given the answers.
They don't want to sit and think
and analyze for themselves.
Or if they do, they
want the creators
to step in and be like,
oh, you are correct.
Yes, you are correct.
Correct answer.
And "Night Vale," the
answers aren't that easy.
If you look up any
of the fan art,
there is huge variations in
what this character, Cecil,
looks like.
And he's never actually
been described.
And what's really fascinating,
is that they range everything
from the sort of Tim
Gunn, blond, "Mad Men"
looking person, to
a person of color,
like Afro-Caribbbean-centric
clothing,
to furry pants and crazy
fashion, to alien, to--
there's a slug one.
It really just runs the gamut.
Whenever people ask me, they're
like, what Cecil look like?
We need to know!
And I'm like, well, what
do you think he looks like?
That answer is correct.
I think living in
that ambiguity is
one of the most beautiful
things about "Night Vale."
We live in this world now
where media is omnipresent.
I mean, you all work at
Google, you know this.
It's everywhere.
We have we have tiny
hand computers that live
in our pockets all the time.
And we have access to that
information all the time.
And that is amazing.
But at the same time, living
with a little bit of ambiguity
in your life can
actually make things kind
of fun and interesting.
So we continue to
make "Night Vale."
We got very, very
popular, very quick,
through a mix of Twitter
and Tumblr and Reddit.
There was like this
one perfect summer
where "Hannibal" was on
hiatus, and "Pacific Rim"
had just come out.
And the nerds were
feeling really strong.
All of a sudden, this
weird podcast that
had a good amount of
listeners, but nothing crazy,
all of a sudden literally
turned into the blueprint
of what it means to go viral.
The interconnectedness of
the world let this happen.
So you have a fan of "Night
Vale" who lives in Australia.
They tell 10 of their
friends about this podcast.
And those 10 people tell
their friends, and et cetera,
et cetera.
But the difference
is, those people
can live all over the world
and have a conversation just
like we're having in this room.
Then it literally just
happened in one summer.
I was visiting a friend.
I'd been fired from my job
as a waiter, literally just
around the corner
here on 10th Avenue.
I think I had enough
money in my bank account
to last three months.
I was like, OK, I'm going
to have a great summer,
and keep it low key.
And then find another
waiter job, like you do.
And then over the course
of that three months,
"Night Vale" started
to become this thing.
Our download numbers became
more and more and more.
Then we surpassed
"This American Life"
as the most downloaded
podcast in the world.
Then we became the most
downloaded podcast in England,
in Australia, et
cetera, et cetera.
Me, Meg Bashwiner, Joseph
Fink, Jeffrey Cranor
looked at each other and went,
I think there's something--
there's a sea change happening,
and we could all feel it.
But we didn't quite
know what it meant.
So we just kept making the work.
We just kept-- we have this
new episodes every two weeks.
We've got to just keep
putting it out there
and just let the noise happen,
and acknowledge it, but then
just funnel everything
into the work.
Then eventually, we did
our first live reading.
And that was in San
Francisco, at a bookstore
called The Booksmith in the
Haight-Ashbury district.
We were like, oh,
it'll be great.
Our friend Mara Wilson is there.
And she is The
Faceless Old Woman Who
Secretly Lives in Your Home.
And she's visiting her friend.
And we'll just have
a fun little reading.
We show up, and there's
hundreds of people there.
It's one of those things
where, as an actor,
when you get on stage, and you
expect to interact with people.
But it's one thing to
interact with 10, 15,
20 people, and then
interact with like 500.
So this was very unexpected.
Eventually, we stopped
pinching ourselves.
Then we're just
like, you know what?
This is just like doing "Too
Much Light Makes the Baby Go
Blind" in the East Village
at 11 o'clock at night.
You just talk to the people,
do the thing, make the art.
That's your job.
It doesn't matter who's in the
audience or how many people.
Eventually it did
start to snowball.
And we were like, OK.
We're theater
writers and actors.
Let's see if we can put
together a live show.
That started us on the next part
of the journey of "Night Vale,"
which is getting
off of the podcast
and then getting it
into the live shows.
We've done live shows all
over the world at this point.
We've performed in churches.
We've performed in rock clubs.
We've performed
in concert halls.
We've performed in theater
theaters, in movie theaters.
We've run the gamut.
Because it all started off as
this very cottage industry.
Literally Jeffrey Cranor
calling up universities
and being like, hey, can we
rent out your lecture hall
to do this show?
And they'd be like, no one's
going to come see this!
Yeah, sure whatever.
And we would do the show,
and then hundreds of people
would show up.
These people were just
like, what is going on?
We've had to learn
a lot about this.
And I think this is a
really interesting model
for a lot of businesses that are
happening right now, where you
do this thing that you love.
And then you keep doing it.
And you do it
because you love it.
And you put it out
there, because you want
to share it with the world.
And then eventually, other
people who love this thing also
find it.
And then they tell their
friends, and et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
But all the stuff that comes
with that is the tricky part.
We're theater actors,
theater writers.
None of us had ever put
together a concert film
or had to deal with writers with
agents and things like that.
This was all kind of new.
So our learning
curve was very steep.
We found ourselves reaching
out to other people
in the podcast community who
were a little bit farther along
than us.
And that has been invaluable.
This is actually from one
of our first live shows.
That's me in the
middle, Mara Wilson
is right above me, who's
this amazing actor, very
famous as a child actor, but now
is a writer, a serious writer,
and Twitter personality.
Next to her is
Jackson Publick, who
is the voice of and creator
of Venture Brothers.
Next to me is Marc
Jackson, who is literally
one of the best improv
people in the world.
You've seen him in a million
TV shows and movies and things
like that.
And then down in
the corner, I think
that's Mark Gagliardi,
who is someone
who I know from growing up, who
is also an improv sketch comedy
person.
Marc and-- Marc and Mark worked
for "The Thrilling Adventure
Hour," which is this
long-standing, old school
Hollywood radio show.
Very, very funny,
very sketch-oriented.
And they have this huge
roster of celebrities
that would be on their show,
because it's just so much fun.
But the "Thrilling Adventure
Hour" team reached out to us,
and was like, hey, this is
how we do our live shows.
Take what you want.
Listen, we have all
these people in LA,
if you ever want funny
actors to come on your show.
And we're like, yes we will.
Absolutely So we just asked
them to come on the show.
And all of a sudden, we
went from doing readings
in bookstores, with
just one or two people.
Joseph's in the back playing
know music off of his iPod.
Then all of a sudden,
we have multiple mics.
And now we're doing staging.
And where's the green room?
Is there a bathroom
in the green room?
What do we do with 12 actors
while they're waiting offstage?
Everybody has to eat.
Who's ordered pizza?
All these logistical questions
that you don't really
think of when you're just
doing it for the fun of it
all of a sudden start
to come into play.
It was a really fun night.
We did two shows that night.
And the show was, I don't
know, like two hours long.
You imagine four hours
of standing onstage
telling a story.
When you're on stage,
time gets kind of weird.
It can either like
feel like forever,
or it can be the
blink of an eye.
That night was definitely
one of those nights
where it was 8 o'clock, and
then all of a sudden I blinked,
and it's 1:00 in the morning.
And I was like, I don't
know where that night went.
But it was a lot of fun.
This is a more recent picture.
This is Dylan Marron
as Carlos and myself,
going back to this idea that
this gay canonical relationship
is at the heart of the show.
Dylan is one of the
kindest, funniest, smartest
actors I've ever had the
pleasure of working with.
And this sort of relationship at
the heart of the show, I think,
was kind of a lynch pin for
the popularity of "Night Vale."
Because it was something that,
no matter where in the world
you lived, you have your
physical community-- the people
that you see everyday, in
your school, your family,
things like that.
Those are the people
that you interact with.
But then you also have
your chosen community,
which for a lot
of people online,
that can be a way for
gay people to connect
with other gay people,
for vegetarians
to connect with
other vegetarians,
whatever it is that you define
your community as being.
I think having this
transparent and very real,
honest look at a
gay relationship
opened a lot of people's eyes
to what a gay relationship is.
And you know what?
It's pretty much the same
as a straight relationship.
"Night Vale" made its
point on focusing on,
who's going to do the dishes?
Who's going to cook
dinner that night?
It's the mundane stuff that
makes people's minds change.
Because you're a listener
and you're like, oh, well,
I'm not gay, but this sounds
exactly like my relationship.
And incorporating that into
the show has done nothing
but make it--
bringing allies on and
changing people's minds.
So there is this social
justice warrior aspect
of the show, that is
not only unapologetic,
but is also kind of necessary.
And especially in
the last few years,
it's been really,
really beneficial.
So let's see.
Like I said, we've had some
really amazing times getting
to tour all over the world.
This was-- Wil Wheaton is
a character on our show.
What's interesting
about doing a show that
is ongoing, and
episodic, and epic
is that you always get a chance
to change things as you go.
So the characters in episode
10 are not the same characters
that are in episode 100.
A lot of back story
has been drawn out.
Because two weeks, you've
got to feed the podcast.
You know the podcasts
will keep on coming out.
So it gives you a
chance to world build.
And it gives you chances
to go off on tangents
and explore little cul-de-sacs,
and then maybe get back
to the main plot, and then
go off on another tangent.
And this episode
is just a monologue
from a totally different
character, and that's OK.
Because again, you're the boss.
When you're creating
this-- when you're
sort of the creator of
something like this,
you don't have
anyone to answer to.
You can follow those things
that you find interesting.
Chances are your audience will
find them interesting as well.
Wil's character was really
interesting, because it was--
I want to say he started
off as just a one-off joke,
where he was a childhood
friend of Cecil's.
Then there was possibly
some romantic interest.
But it was very subtext,
sub-sub-subtext.
And then the internet
exploded, and they were like,
don't you mess with Carlos!
Who is this interloper
trying to horn
in our favorite
gay relationship?
The writers, being who
they are, they're like, OK,
I see what the audience thinks.
We're going to go the
totally opposite direction.
He becomes this childhood
friend of Cecil,
who just builds back story.
And Wil's character is a
chef at a very trendy, trendy
restaurant in Night
Vale called Tourniquet.
And he's always
coming onto the show
and doing cooking
segments that are just
the most horrific things you've
ever heard in your entire life.
Wil is the nicest person.
He's so down to earth.
Again, it's like he
got the sense of humor,
being one of these
king of the nerds
that are out there in the world.
It made it really
interesting, because not
only is that relationship
between creator and listener,
it's reflexive.
We make something, and then
we send it out into the world,
and the world reacts to it.
And then we react
to that reaction.
Again, one of the reasons
why technology can really
help, because all of a
sudden, that is instantaneous.
Then I think Wil's
character is a definite--
it shows how that can
flourish and progress.
This is Joseph Fink
the middle, the creator
"Welcome to Night Vale."
Symphony Sanders,
who's a dear friend
of mine, who voices
Tamika Flynn.
And then Erin McKeown
down on the side there.
One of the interesting
things about "Night Vale"
is that every episode
includes a song
by an independent
musical artist.
These range from hip hop
to folk to pop to anything,
as long as it falls squarely
in the musicians just trying
to get their work out there.
Erin McKeown is this
amazing musician,
who is an Ani DiFranco
protege back in the day,
and then has just continued to
make her own music for years.
We found her, we snatched her
up, because she's awesome.
She makes great music.
She's a lot of
fun to tour with--
very important-- and also
brings a really great energy
to the show.
It's so funny.
When you are at work,
the people around you
really define the
quality of the work.
You want to find people
that challenge you,
that support you, and also
help you think differently
than you already think, but
also know how you think.
So that way, somebody gives
you an idea, and you're like,
I never in a million years
would I have thought about that.
But I love it.
And now, here's what
I can add to it.
The relationship between
the writers and myself,
the other actors that
appear on the show,
we all have this sort
of working relationship.
It's really great,
because we get
to go and do this show live in
front of hundreds of people.
Every night is a
little bit different,
because that's live theater.
Symphony and I are constantly
refining and working
on the comedy of the show.
And you're like, OK, this
joke didn't work tonight.
Maybe if we try it this way?
OK.
It worked a little bit better.
OK, let's try adding this.
Let's try doing this.
So every night is a little
bit of an experiment.
Again, going back to this idea
of a little bit of ambiguity
is actually OK.
A little bit of an
experiment is OK.
You get out there, you
know the work is solid.
You know what you're doing.
But around the
periphery, you can also
play around a little bit.
Sometimes that's
where the magic lives.
Because you'll find things
that your conscious brain never
in a million years
would have thought of.
But all of a sudden,
when you're live in front
of a group of people, and you do
something-- you react honestly.
You look at a person
in the eye, and you
react using the language
that you've been given,
all of a sudden, magic happens.
This is Jon Bernstein, a.k.a.
Disparition, who has also been
in on the show "Night Vale"
since the ground floor.
Joseph knew Jon from
way back in the day.
I think he worked at Something
Awful, if you remember that.
They worked there together.
Jon is this brilliant
musician who
makes the most beautiful
ambient music you've ever heard.
He had just a whole
canon of music
that he put out into
the internet for free.
Joseph said hey, do you mind
if I use some of your music
as background for "Night Vale."
And Jon was like, yeah, sure.
It's just sitting there.
So we started incorporating
his music into the show.
And then eventually, once
the show started taking off,
Jon started writing
specifically for "Night Vale."
Now he tours with us,
and he plays live.
He live underscores
the entire show.
He plays mandolin.
He has a keyboard.
He has all the tech wizardry
that happens over here
in the corner while I'm
talking into a microphone.
What's great about this
is, it just incorporates
another layer of
look-- here are people,
here are a group
of artists, actors,
writers musicians, who are
doing what they love to do.
And you love to
watch them do it.
And we're going
to sit in a room.
It's the simplest, oldest
formula in the world--
storytellers telling a story,
musicians playing music,
and people listening.
That's all you need.
When I was back
in theater school,
a teacher asked us
to define theater.
And we're like, oh,
it's got to be Broadway,
it's got to be this.
She was like, no, think simpler.
Eventually we got it down
to a performs b for c.
That's it.
That's the only
formula that you need
for theater and storytelling.
You need people to perform, you
need what they're performing,
and you need someone to listen.
So we've created this
theater troupe, essentially,
like a theater troupe
in the older sense,
like the Elizabethan sense.
We act, we set up, we
do our own green room,
we drive from place to place.
We handle not only the artistic
side, but also the business
side of stuff as well.
I find that that's getting
rarer and rarer these days,
because it's a lot of work.
It requires a lot of
attention to detail.
And it involves expanding
your skill set all the time
to incorporate things
that you might not
be totally comfortable with.
But, you know what?
There's nothing better
than learning on your feet.
This is one of my
favorite venues.
It's in Vancouver.
This was the end of
one of the last tours.
You imagine going from doing
a reading in a bookstore,
and then we're performing
in places like this, two,
three years later.
We've sold out this--
we've done almost sold out shows
in this theater, this venue,
I think three times now.
It's the most beautiful
theater in the world.
It's acoustically perfect.
No microphones necessary.
It's one of my favorite
places to play.
And it's also just
this gorgeous--
Vancouver is amazing.
So it's always fun
to have a stop there.
This is another
one of those venues
that we just had
to pinch ourselves
that we were performing at.
So this is The
Palladium in London.
This is the equivalent of going
to the Nederlander Theater
on Broadway.
It's this huge venue.
It's owned by
Andrew Lloyd Webber.
You walk outside, and you're
in the middle of the heart
of Oxford, in London.
Me and my friends were
just like, I can't--
what-- what did we do?
How did we end up here?
We're wandering around, silently
walking through the crowd
outside waiting to
get into the show.
And most people
don't recognize us
when we're just average
everyday people.
And also London is
filled with people.
So you can't really take it in.
But we were just like,
look at all these people!
They're here for us.
Can you believe this?
This is crazy!
The energy before that show
was absolutely unbelievable,
because we're in
a foreign country.
We're outside of
our comfort zone.
We're outside of our home.
And yet, we still feel like we
are at home, because we're just
doing what we love to do.
It's the same show that we had
done 50, 60, 70 times before.
And so there's a level
of comfort-ability.
But the electricity in
the room was amazing,
because this is
2,400 people, which
I think was the largest
show "Night Vale" had ever
done to date.
And then this is what I
look like after the show.
So "Night Vale" has
been this blessing.
It has been this very,
very strange journey, one
that I'm still on, that
allows me to come to Google,
and to say yes, I'm
going to stand up
in front of a room of people
and tell you my story.
And hopefully there's
something that you
can take away from that.
If anything, I think the
blessing of "Night Vale"
is just keep doing
what you're doing.
Keep making the work.
When I had been fired from that
restaurant, five years ago,
six years ago, and I had no
idea what I was going to do,
and I had no idea where
the money would come from,
the only thing that
was never in doubt
was, I'm not going to quit.
I'm not going to drop out and
just be like, you know what?
Screw it.
I'm done.
I've had enough.
You have to keep making the
work that you love to do,
and then eventually that
will blossom into something
that other people
will pay you to do,
that will allow you
to live your life
and then focus on that work.
Then once that happens, the
groundwork is already set,
and you are in the mindset to
be like, no, this is my job.
This is what I love.
I would say that--
to anyone who moves
New York City to work in the
arts, work in anything, really.
You work all day
to make your rent.
Then at the end of
your day you go home,
and that's when the
real work begins.
That's when you start to
work on the projects that
really like feed your
soul, that give you life.
Then if you're lucky,
and if you persist,
then those projects
eventually become
the job that pay your rent.
Then all of a sudden,
you marry those two.
That's what New
York was made for.
I love what I do.
I love it so much.
And I love to be able to
get to talk to people.
And I welcome the chance to
answer any questions you have.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's find a good
background slide.
There we go.
All right.
SPEAKER: We do encourage you
guys to think of your questions
and to make your way to
the microphone for that.
We definitely want to
hear from all of you.
I do have a couple to get
us started, if that's OK.
I wanted to talk first about
the horror element in the show.
I know you spent a great deal of
time talking about the comedy.
But I wanted to reference
the horror part of it.
Because it very much is a
horror story, or at least taking
place in a horror setting.
But it's not a
contemporary horror.
It's not gory in any way.
It's not really filled
with jump scares.
So I was wondering
if you could talk
about the influence
of the horror
background and the setting.
CECIL BALDWIN: Sure.
It was definitely present
from the very beginning,
like that pilot episode.
And I think one of
the reasons that I
was so fortunate to become
part of this project
is because I knew the guys.
I knew their voice.
I'd heard their writing.
And I'd heard them
speak their own writing.
And so I knew what was funny
and also what was scary.
Let's say if they had
just had an audition,
and put it out in
"Backstage," being like,
oh, we need a voiceover actor.
I don't think
another actor would
have gotten to that humor
or that horror as quickly.
Because I read that pilot
script, and I was like,
oh, it's "Twin Peaks."
Oh, it's "Blue Velvet."
OK, great, I know how something
that's very simple and mundane
can become very
scary and unnerving.
Have you all seen "Blue Velvet?"
Kyle MacLachlan's character,
in the first 10 minutes,
finds an ear, like
just out in the grass.
It's the idea of something
very normal, something
very simple that
we see every day,
literally thousands
of times a day,
but taken out of its context
can become terrifying.
And I think a lot of the
horror of "Night Vale"
is really based on that.
Something like finding
a cassette tape
that you made when
you were a teenager,
and reveling in that
nostalgia of like,
oh, listen to how cute I
was, little teenage me!
But then at the end of that
cassette tape, you die.
And you don't know what
killed you or what happened.
But you're definitely here now.
And this is real.
And I feel real.
And it's all those
questions in that.
I think that's where the
scariness of "Night Vale"
lies, is in that
unexplained phenomena.
SPEAKER: Sure.
The unexplained is a
really key element.
And I think you
guys do that a lot,
with a lot of the characters.
Like you were saying,
leaving out detail
to allow that to be filled in.
It works in a very "Twilight
Zone," "Outer Limits"
kind of way.
There's clearly
something going on,
CECIL BALDWIN: But nobody
can put their finger on it.
SPEAKER: Are there plans
to start explaining--
CECIL BALDWIN: No.
Why would there?
[LAUGHING]
What's interesting is that the
way "Night Vale" is structured
is that, because it was very
home grown in the beginning,
it wasn't until episode 10 or 15
that we're like, whoa, whoa, we
should probably start recording
and keeping track of some
of these characters, and what
they do and what they've done.
What's interesting about
doing this episodic show
is that a joke, literally a one
sentence joke from episode 3,
all of a sudden can turn
into an entire plot line that
takes over an entire season.
That is our way of going
back and explaining things.
Simple characters like
Wil Wheaton's character
is a good example, where it
was just a little one-off joke.
Cecil was in Boy
Scouts, and he was
in Boy Scouts with this guy.
And then all of a
sudden, that goes off
in a totally
different tangent that
now is taken that
character relationship
to a different place.
I think what's
interesting is that there
are these sort of
demigods in "Night
Vale," these strange,
unexplained, powerful
creatures.
And I think, if
anything, "Night Vale"
will probably start filling
in the gaps in some of those.
SPEAKER: And some of
that eldritch horror
has to have day jobs.
CECIL BALDWIN: Because what
makes the eldritch abomination
so terrifying is that
it is indescribable.
SPEAKER: Right.
CECIL BALDWIN: And when
you start to describe it,
your brain scrambles,
and people go mad.
The un-know-edness of that
is what makes it scary.
I would say the
scariest thing is
what lies just beyond the
circle of light from a campfire.
Going back to that
idea of, if I was
to describe to you every aspect
of the mad man that has escaped
from the insane asylum
that's out there in the woods
somewhere, I'm feeding
you that information.
I'm giving it you,
so that way you
don't have to do the work of--
what is this person?
What is he--
It's much more terrifying to
imagine that for yourself,
to not know, and to live
in that not knowing.
That's so much scarier.
SPEAKER: The unknown, or the
things that are foreign to us
are typically the
scariest things.
Which leads me to
another interesting point
that I want to talk
about, which is the--
you touched a lot on
the relationship that's
at the core of the story.
And it's not really heavy
handed, like you've explained,
but it's led you to a lot of
activism in that LGBTQ space.
Discuss those things.
How do you use the
vehicle of the show
and just the normalcy of
it to then turn to advocacy
when you're outside the space.
CECIL BALDWIN: Sure.
What's interesting
is, that "Night Vale,"
for all of its craziness
and scariness, is pretty PG.
Crazy, terrible things
happen, don't get me wrong,
but it's still kind of
a family friendly show
in a weird sort of way.
And it's very inclusive.
I find that when I meet people,
fans, at live shows and online
and things like
that, oftentimes it's
multiple generations of people
that have discovered the show.
Because there is this
LGBT aspect to it--
my character and Dylan's
character, Carlos.
The angels are non-gendered
beings, et cetera, et cetera.
It's really interesting,
because a lot of young fans
get into the show, and then
use "Night Vale" as a gateway
to talk to their parents, or
their friends, or coworkers,
or whatever on who they are.
They've been like, OK,
look, I know I'm 14
and I just came
out of the closet.
And I have no idea
what's happening
to my emotions or my body.
And I have to process
all this information
and talk to my parents about it.
Here, mom, dad.
Here is a podcast
that represents how
I feel about this whole thing.
It's kind of strange, in that
it is such a bizarre show.
But it is so based in
normal human relationships.
I think that's what
makes it so relatable.
SPEAKER: Normalization
is huge, I think,
in all forms of
advocacy, anytime.
Because it's that unfamiliarity
that makes it scary,
or the misinformation.
So I love that element of it.
We've got a couple questions.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
CECIL BALDWIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You have these
amazing live shows that you do.
Now that the show is
as popular as it is,
do you write and craft and
rehearse privately, and then
workshop it live, and then
go record it for the public?
Because you said you do 40,
50, 60 sometimes performances.
And you find these moments
live, in true theater.
Does the episode recording
come first, and then
live, or vice versa?
CECIL BALDWIN: The live show
is separate from the podcast.
You know the podcast comes
out once every two weeks.
The boys write an episode.
They sign off on it.
They send it to me.
I record it at home,
send it back to them,
and they put it up online.
The live shows were made to be
separate for a couple reasons.
It acknowledges the fact that
everyone's in the same room,
probably is the most
fundamental thing.
Again, back to this idea
of you are who you are,
you are where you are, you're
doing what you're doing.
If you're live on stage,
you can't deny that.
We have played around
with a lot of ideas of,
oh, you're listening
to a radio show,
but we all know you're really
in a theater in Vancouver
on a Tuesday night.
It also allows
people who are not
super-fans of the podcast
to walk in and get
what's going on.
The story of the live
shows-- every year
we do a different script.
And we run that show for a year.
We try to tour to as
many places as possible
and get that live
script to them.
Then we finish it,
we're like, great.
Then we release that online.
Jon Bernstein, he records
pretty much every live show
that we do.
Then at the end of
that yearly cycle,
he'll take his favorite moments,
each section by section,
and then find--
OK, well, we had Desiree
Burch was in Germany
for this one show in Cologne.
And that was the best me
and Desiree have ever done.
We're going to take
that recording,
and then put that together
with Geoffrey did a monologue.
It's his character.
And [? Philly ?] nailed it.
So we're going to like
cobble that together.
And then that's what we release.
I think we do a suggested
donation on Bandcamp of $1.
So it's really more
about make the work,
get it out there, rather than
let's commodify this to death.
What's great about
that is, when you
are in this mindset of
work, work, work, work.
Just get out there
and do the thing.
It allows for these
unexpected moments to pop up.
We don't do improv.
It's a script.
It's all scripted.
Joseph and Jeffrey have written
the live performance script.
But what you can't
control in the moment
is audience reactions.
It's what you ate for
dinner that night.
It's all these human
elements that become
the sort of mystery factor.
All of a sudden,
Symphony Sanders
will say something
that just cracks me up.
You can either deny that moment
and pretend like it never
happened, which a lot of
mainstream theater is built on.
Or you can allow it to happen,
acknowledge it, and then
incorporate it into
the performance.
And if it's something
that's truly amazing
you do it again the next night.
But the trick is, you can't
recreate that mystery factor.
It has to be real and organic.
Or you go, you know what?
That was hilarious.
Tomorrow night it
won't be there,
because it won't feel real.
So you're riding that line
between doing the best
show possible,
sticking to the script,
but then also being open
to external stimulus
and the truth of the moment.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CECIL BALDWIN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Please, go ahead.
CECIL BALDWIN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So awesome
to have you here.
CECIL BALDWIN: Oh, thanks.
AUDIENCE: You said that you
act as your own director
when you're recording.
But a lot of the
tone of "Night Vale"
comes from the
specificity of your voice
and the way you say things.
I was wondering
how much of this is
stage directions in the
script, and how much of it
it's just you.
CECIL BALDWIN: OK.
That's a that's a
really great question,
because what's interesting
is there's no stage
directions in the script.
It is really-- there's
two books out now
that are the first year and
the second year of "Night
Vale" scripts.
And if you look at those,
maybe there's a door slam,
maybe there's shuffling papers.
But that's it.
Everything else is
just words on a page.
My background-- I did a lot of
classical theater in my 20s,
like a lot of Shakespeare,
Moliere, things like that.
What's great about
that training is
that's exactly how
Shakespeare worked.
The Elizabethans would
go listen to a play.
They wouldn't go to
watch a play, kind
of what we think about now.
The actors would
take this poetry.
And there'd be very little
visual element, kind of basic.
It was performed outside,
under full sunlight.
There's people selling
oranges, and prostitutes,
and shady business deals,
and highbrow and lowbrow
and everything in between.
It was this carnival atmosphere.
But a play was going on.
Some of the most beautiful
poetry in the world
was being spoken.
The Elizabethans could
pick up on that poetry,
because they tuned in
their ears to listen to it.
So I find when I'm at
home in my living room,
recording an episode,
I approach the language
of "Night Vale" with the
same reverence as I would,
"To be or not to be."
Because that's all you have.
Like right now, I'm
sitting in front of you.
We're looking at each other.
I'm using my hands
to emphasize a point.
We have these
secondary gestures,
secondary communication.
All that is taken away
when you do a radio show.
You have to take
all of that and then
focus it just on the words.
I find that's the biggest trick.
There are times when
I'll record a segment,
and I'll go back and listen.
I'm like, oh, it
sounds a little flat.
Not because the writing
is flat or the performance
is flat, just because it's
not heightened enough.
It's not intense enough.
You have to overshoot
the mark with intensity,
especially when there's
no visual element to it.
And you're talking about
crazy things happening.
There's a woman who's
visiting our town.
And she's taking
over people's brains
and making them say poetry
in a rhythmic chant.
You can't go too far.
Oftentimes the ideas that
I have in the moment that
are like, why did this
character sound like this?
I don't know.
It sounded interesting
at the time.
Those were the most--
those are the longest
lasting ideas.
Because you're just
like, I don't know.
I followed this down this rabbit
hole, and that's where we are.
Those are often the characters
that people really love.
SPEAKER: Have you ever had
that go counter to what
the guys' writing to
where they were like,
oh, this was meant
to be a laugh line.
CECIL BALDWIN: Oh, absolutely.
There was one
character, Leanne Hart.
She's a blogger, I believe?
No, she is a local
newspaper editor.
And her thing is that
she hates bloggers.
And she wants to kill
them all with an axe.
That's her thing.
Again, like a one-off
character, and then eventually
she got an episode where
she was very present.
And she speaks.
I was like, well, she seems
to be kind of unhinged.
She gets more and more unhinged
as the episode goes on.
What started off as a very
normal sounding character
all of a sudden
turned into the Joker
from Batman by the end of it.
She gets crazy.
I recorded the episode.
I sent it off to
Joseph and Jeffrey.
They were like, OK, yeah.
Leanne is actually a character
in like some upcoming episodes,
and she can't be
totally batshit insane.
Pull it back a little.
And I was like, great.
That I can do.
One of the easiest
things in the world
is to dial something down.
It's much harder to
increase it in intensity.
I find, start at 10, and
then start pulling it down,
so you hit that sweet spot.
SPEAKER: Nice.
Please.
CECIL BALDWIN: Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
One of the most interesting
things to me about "Night Vale"
is how it does work to normalize
a vast swath of humanity.
And it does it through horror.
A lot of times in
horror, the other
is used as something
to fear, something
to project everything
evil against.
Whereas in "Night Vale," to
accept the premise of the show,
you have to understand that a
severed hand from a Russian man
is a teenage girl.
CECIL BALDWIN: Absolutely
AUDIENCE: Or that there are
literally five-headed dragons
around.
CECIL BALDWIN: And they're going
to run for a mayoral office.
Because what else would they do?
AUDIENCE: So could you talk
a little bit about that?
Like how you turn horror around?
CECIL BALDWIN:
Well I think what's
interesting about "Night
Vale" is that, at its heart,
it is about community.
It's about this American town.
What I love about Joseph and
Jeffrey's writing is that,
it's not writing America as
it is perceived by itself.
Things on TV, you think
about the nuclear family
sitcom and what that is.
Is that real?
Is that how we see ourselves?
Or is that how a certain
section of the population
want to see ourselves?
And I think Joseph
and Jeffrey are
much better at incorporating
everybody into this community.
So then it becomes
the horror of what
lies outside that community.
Cecil, at his heart, loves
the town of "Night Vale."
And everyone in that
community is beloved by him.
Because he sees the
importance of this
interconnectedness of these
communities that we live in.
So then the scary stuff
comes from outside of that.
If you notice, a lot of the--
to borrow the Buffy term,
the "big bad," every
season has the big bad.
It's an outside
corporation, or it's
an outside town that is trying
to take over "Night Vale."
It is someone who
accidentally summons
the devil in the form of--
it goes on.
Always the big bad is
always an outside thing
that is attacking the fabric
of what "Night Vale" is,
which is this accepting
community that
supports each other.
Even when you can't stand
each other, you still know.
You're like, yes, this
is my step-brother.
His name is Steve Carlsberg.
And I hate him.
But he's still my step-brother.
And so I love him.
And it's playing with
that relationship.
The people in "Night Vale" very
rarely are the scary thing.
It's always something
that's invading that.
And I think that does
a lot to remind people
that no matter where
you're at in your life,
the outside world is terrifying.
Literally pick up the news
and just look at Twitter,
and just be like, OK, what am I
going to be terrified of today?
But eventually you're
going to get through it.
That's the takeaway
of "Night Vale."
The scarier it gets, the
more hopeful it gets.
Because at the end
of the episode,
Cecil doesn't know where the
next episode is going to be,
what's going to happen tomorrow.
But he's like, no, all I know
is that this community has
my back.
And I am the voice
of this community.
And we move on from there.
SPEAKER: That's great.
They're all the frogs
in the boiling water.
So the glass of room temperature
tap water is terrifying.
CECIL BALDWIN: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
They're like, well, we've
gotten used to this now.
SPEAKER: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What's
the one question
you wish someone had
asked you, but never has.
CECIL BALDWIN: Oh, man.
The one question I wish
somebody would ask me?
I don't know.
I always love the question,
what is your dream project?
It's very-- I don't think
anybody has ever asked me that.
And it seems very staple of--
if you could do anything,
what would you do?
Yeah.
I think that's it.
SPEAKER 1: OK, now actually
answer the question.
CECIL BALDWIN: As a
fan of horror movies
and Shakespeare and all
these disparate things--
has anybody ever seen this
movie, "Theater of Blood."
Do you know this movie at all?
It's like super campy
Vincent Price, Diana Rigg
movie, in which Vincent Price
plays a Shakespearean actor who
fakes his own death, goes crazy,
develops a theater company made
of homeless people,
and then exacts revenge
on all the critics
that panned him
when he was a legit
Shakespeare actor,
and kills them in ways
that are designated
by the player he was in that
they wrote bad reviews of.
He was Titus Andronicus,
and so he takes the critic
and bakes their dogs
into a pie kind of thing.
I've always wanted to do
a remake of that film.
If anybody has any ideas--
writers, directors,
please come see me.
Because that is literally--
this incorporates everything
in my brand, everything
that I get excited about.
That's my dream project.
SPEAKER 1: I did
want to ask about--
and this might be
where we wrap up.
Thanks for your question.
I did want to ask
about the future of--
the larger IP.
You guys have a wildly
engaged audience.
A lot of the artwork
that you showed
was brought to you from
the subreddit, from Tumblr,
and the community.
I wanted to ask about
the future of the IP,
and what you guys
might have planned,
as far as expanding it.
Because it does
seem like you could
go in a film kind of direction,
or in a television series
kind of direction.
Maybe a role-playing game.
CECIL BALDWIN: Oh my god, yeah.
The hardest part about it
is, there's no boundaries.
One of the things
that we learned
working with the
Neo-Futurists is
that putting
boundaries on things
actually lets you
be more creative.
It defines your sandbox.
These are the box of crayons.
It doesn't matter if
you have five colors
or if you have 5,000 colors.
What you can produce
from that is infinite.
But you only have five--
those are the parameters.
What's interesting about where
"Night Vale" is heading next
is, we are limited by
our own experiences
and what we know to do.
Would I love to see a Magic:
The Gathering-style card
game of "Night Vale?"
Hell yes I would!
I would play that all day.
Would I love to see a
Off-Broadway musical
about "Night Vale?"
Yeah, absolutely.
But I can't write--
I'm not a musical person.
I have a limited amount
of knowledge in that area.
I can't be like, you know what,
I'm going to write a musical.
It would take a lot of work and
a lot of years to get there.
I've never line
produced a TV show
or been a show
runner on a TV show.
We're finding ourselves
having to align ourselves
with people that are as
passionate about the project
as we are, and as passionate
about the integrity
of the project, and also
have those skill sets.
Those things take time.
Those people are
definitely out there,
but it's all about
finding them, in the way
that the "Thrilling Adventure
Hour" people found us,
so we found them.
It was like oh, you get this.
Because there's
nothing worse than--
I think everybody
here is very savvy.
You can tell when a project
was made just for a cash grab.
When you're like, OK, we totally
rebooted this thing one more
time just so some people
can make some money.
But there's no heart into it.
I think "Night Vale" is
the opposite of that,
in that we would
rather do the work
and feel passionate about it.
And if it takes us 10
years to make a film,
it took us 10 years
to make a film.
If it takes us 20 years
to make a card game--
which seems a bit extreme--
but that's how long it took.
But you better
believe that we all
felt the best about it
every step of the way.
I think that's an unusual thing.
People talk a lot
about selling out
and da-da-da and
this whole thing.
It's not so black and
white as all that.
You've just got
to make decisions
based on the information
that's in front of you.
Someday if these many
things come to pass,
that'd be amazing.
But you want to do it right.
I think it's better to feel
passionate about the work
than it is to to get
it out there in order
to just have it be out
there, and pay your mortgage
or whatever.
SPEAKER 1: Well, I
think the fandom now
has new marching orders.
For the next four
months, you're going
to get "Night Vale:
The Gathering"
magic cards to your inbox.
CECIL BALDWIN:
Great, let's do it.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you, Cecil so much.
CECIL BALDWIN: Absolutely.
Thank you so much.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
so much for joining us.